the moment you knew he was really good
seven in my phone he's up on the ground
he's very mature for his age he's always
been calm cool and collected he was
checking off at seven years old and
Daddy was over there calling the place
for him and grooming him and I taught
him all defenses first that's why we
didn't Flinch last week that's why two
yard line 98 yards cool minute 40 minute
whatever it was on the clock cool he's
done that before we got that he don't
Flinch and he loves those moments what
was funny was his brother came to me in
overtime and he rarely ever calls me dad
on the field he know him play that he's
like Dad you putting the defense out
there first I said y'all didn't stop
nobody all day your brother going out
there and I know what he gonna do that
really happened because I like to put
pressure on people I don't like people
putting the pressure on us I know he's
going to apply instant pressure and he
did